[Music]
despite the success that you that you're
having and you're getting more and more
well-known that you still get mistaken
for other actors is that right yeah I do
I'm chelsea peretti as someone people
always think I am on Brooklyn nine-nine
and Kristen Schaal and I also get DJ
Qualls all the time we have pictures of
some of these people up that you get
mistaken for I know you don't look like
there's you on the top left you don't
look like you know that's not right oh
yeah the girl from spider-man Manitoba
yeah yeah but people think I'm DJ I mean
I don't think I'm him they write to me
everyday and tell me we're siblings or
something I mean he's great I just I
like to be myself yeah you're so much
taller in person do you get that a lot
from people yeah people are really
surprised by that yeah people that have
seen you on oranges and you back and
they think okay she might be I get that
to where anywhere I go places people
think okay I thought you might be kind
of tall but not that tall yeah yeah and
I was surprised I finally get to say it
to someone else there were so much
taller than I thought yeah you too
you turned it back on me the whole point
I think you both look like DJ Qualls
there you got us
[Music]
you